el presidente de perú da la cara ante la
justicia a pedro castillo se le acusa de
ser líder de una presunta conspiración
criminal que recibió sobornos por
contratos de obras públicas su
comparecencia ante la fiscalía se dio a
pesar de la solicitud de su defensa para
que se anulara cualquier investigación
en su contra asegurando que el
mandatario goza de inmunidad absoluta
mientras ejerce como presidente así que
le dijo al pueblo peruano que es
inocente y que se presenta al poder
judicial sólo para aclarar la situación
a pesar de los obstáculos de mentiras y
señalamientos pido a los peruanos
confianza en que todos los objetivos
planteados por el gobierno del pueblo se
harán realidad trabajando juntos porque
el perú está por encima de cualquier
circunstancia
aparte del mandatario la fiscalía ha
extendido la investigación a otros
funcionarios públicos castillo ha
sobrevivido a dos intentos de
destitución en el congreso lo que
refleja la inestabilidad política
peruana desde 2016 con cinco presidentes
distintos desde entonces y al menos tres
disoluciones del congreso
es una persona corrupta comprobada que
está porque está en la fiscalía porque
la gente corrupta gente pagada vende
obras primero
de
tiempo a pesar de que la primera vez en
la historia reciente de perú que un
presidente es investigado durante su
gestión entre 1985 y 2020 seis
presidentes peruanos han enfrentado
acusaciones de corrupción